hey guys and welcome to gamespot
presents the mix at GDC 2016 i'm mary
and i am here with rocky you're here
from a coffee powered machine you're
gonna show me a pretty interesting game
called Oh close but it's a it's like
basically you are controlling little
people that you that worship you and
your kind of like wreaking havoc on a
town yeah actually it's like you are a
philosopher and you have two together an
angry mob of Greek people again angry
you're basically controlling angry I'm
angry mob yeah well as my family used to
always say the masses are asses let's
get into this and right now you can
already see you're acquiring people by
simply running on train em by touching
them if you home us you say you're a
philosopher but I would almost like
compared you to like some kind of um
mauritius like a religious thing yeah we
don't leave people are kind of following
you like Jesus but you use them for
mostly harm you're using them as an
aggressive mob so you can see him right
here he's got the 1p above him and
that's that's the moon philosopher
actually you you control a lot of
philosophers you can search around yeah
and not switch around but anytime is
someone kills your guy you will start
controlling the next philosopher okay so
you you should always be sure to have a
philosopher's right now I only have this
one so if I die it's it's game over for
me you're gonna have backups so that if
you they're basically like extra lives
if you don't bring it alive oh yeah but
like going back to the main gameplay so
all these dudes are following basically
it looks it's um take a little sign that
you have your little signpost yeah and
they follow that and they do what you
tell them from following it um sure I
talk to the fans that's right they're
attacking this like giant Greek dude
over there he's got a lot of health and
he can hurt your people right so each of
these people use
as well as you you can feed them in the
lower left hand corner you have a d-pad
with that you have different options
that you can do as you I know you can
feed them to give everybody a big boost
of health they're all excited actually
you have like five types of units that
you a six types of units you can have
the philosophers are as you said your
your lives the the slaves are the ones
who controls the EIT who can carry items
if you don't have the slaves in your mob
you can't do a use the items for example
I have this this weird helmet that will
spawn on a phantom mode that you will
stay for me a few minutes working with
me and you also have made a shield with
that all makes i use took a big chunk
out of here hey I vote today yeah
curious here's another philosopher but I
don't have a space in my mouth you see
oh then try you know 25 out of 25 which
is the max but if somebody in your mob
were to die yeah I have to make someone
die okay no but can you do that on
purpose would you don't want to
purposely kill your mom know we should
have that ok we're happening right now
did you just get them all hi no that's
if you get near you will get drowsy with
these oracular smokes things but you
just have them destroy it for you yeah
hey the philosopher you're the character
your character is the one that can't get
near those but any other it's ok the
units in the game are very Expendables
and now for example because so much it's
like hurling bodies and bodies and
whatever you want when they die like you
just get new ones a little cruel on it
yeah that's that's the mugger see this
is like back in the day we're like just
the leaders I curled their men at
whatever they wanted and so be it like
what kinds of things are you trying to
achieve with this like with all your
power your are you just murdering people
are you trying to get on well actually
there there's some kind of philosophical
point in the game because o it I did get
killed yeah but the point is that you
have to overthrow the gods and you have
in in each world we can escape the
tutorial about yeah yeah yeah in each
world you have to destroy the world the
god of the world and for example in
Delphi you you have a Apollo and Sparta
you will have and I shall [ __ ] again
I'm very sorry that that screen
shouldn't be there and I don't know how
to put it Oh out of this area no how'd
you read the game guy I'll just escape
it will go back do you want to restart
it from scratch yeah okay so we'll come
back to us for a second and we will
marry start it Oh work in progress you
know none of these games are done these
are all works in progress but speaking
of which how far along are you in
development well we've been working
again like for four years now uh-huh we
started in november two thousand twelve
and we are very near a competition right
now it's like we have 3-4 months maybe
and we really want to rub to get a rub
up the game hey basically it's like we
will keep working on it forever it's
like you want you sometimes because you
see very little things that you have to
work you have to address but yeah we we
we have to finish the game like I hope
for soon maybe yeah and this is coming
out on pc and linux and also iOS is
coming out mobile no no just pc and
linux and I'm Mac may be okay and maybe
Mac for lucky No No maybe no definitely
market okay but maybe that's why it says
iOS maybe this is the tutorial and now
we can at least see a tutorial sure we
can but you know we
kind of understand like the basics of it
like as you're touching people to
acquire them in you have this twin stick
shooter scheme where with one stick you
control the character I'm with the other
ste you control were they the flag we go
we don't have a name for the flag it's
like it's just a flag for us like your
attack barometer and like what's
interesting about is not only can you
attack people but you can attack
barriers and building almost everything
in this world is destructible with
everything in the game everything in
this game is destructible we don't
accept the heels yeah this is the
boundaries of the game right but in
order to destroy buildings you have to
to build up the de gosh they're the
green the green bar and that's very
tricky it's like you really have to
visit a tutorial sold it will not show
up here but you really have to be
destroying a lot of things in order to
to have the demo go shot maximum is it
based on a lot in an amount of time or
just yeah kind of like a certain amount
of like a window of time in order to
raise the bar yeah it's it's about that
it will slowly keep getting lower so
yeah it's like you have to keep on
rubbish right you have to keep
destroying things and this is the store
and because of the trace is closed but
here is where you you exchanged every
type of unit for four heroes the heroes
are a special type of unit where each
year will give you like a special
ability or we make that the mob will
gain I don't know fifty percent of
attack power yeah we good animation of
walking he just looks like you've
dancing yeah it's it's kind of weird but
because I'm the artist of the game I
have a very hard time trying to explain
how the sprite in the game should move
in a free world because we're sir we are
mixing the sprite the pixel sprite and
the all the buildings and all the stage
that it's actually three and that's not
very tricky because the characters move
only in this axis you see that if he
owes up or down we just sinker we don't
care if a how he works but with larger
enemies well you can
spot that they move weird we do have
that problem with the gods beds with
with some of the enemy screen we do have
and what other kind of enemies can we
expect to see like obviously there's a
lot of guards but will there be any kind
of bosses or large-scale enemies at the
end of each other you you will have to
face a god hey one of the Olympian gods
you can face Apollo's a RS Hades shoes
you have lots of a enemy so I'm not so
they're hidden in the game a cigarette
Tsubasa's which are like the minotaur
the hydra they're getting killed on the
spikes how do you keep them so contains
like this kind of thing like really
freaks me out it it makes me feel like
later on you're gonna have areas where I
have to navigate groups of 25 p.m. or
any little alleyways yeah you can have a
until like an 100 people you can when
you have a trade off when you when you
run that the people disperse but with
the lb button you can collapse them so
it's very easy to control them when
they're collapse the trade-off of this
is that they attack they attack power
goes very very Down Goes Down so it's
you shouldn't attack when the mall Vista
collapse here you can see it's based on
like whether or not you are traversing a
precarious area with spikes or you're
just trying to kill everything inside
you expand and compress your mom exactly
alright sweetie oh no will that meat
actually hurt your mom that mate yeah
note playing yeah yeah it does but in
the long run you see they start taking
damage because it's like it's potion and
if you have them like all near they
start providing the the play so you
should like run and make every unit
which is sick too to be far from each
other
or they will get a contagious and spread
their disease right now because this is
an expert mode our expert they are a
special build the the effect just left a
shift left like 10 seconds or so mm-hmm
this is the ship that make you I'm
vulnerable ten seconds well it's pretty
okay you just get to destroy everything
in sight very open yeah yeah we're in
this instance where we have to balance a
lot of the game of course that's yeah
it's extremely open and now that I'm in
May occultic mob I can destroy buildings
so basically this whole yes you you've
increased your meet me today yeah so now
you're like insane your mega mobs
killing everything yeah and i can
destroy buildings but we're qing in the
tutorial because in the tutorial the
more the bar doesn't go down okay and
that's that's just like murdering
everyone yeah well they were shipped
East it's to try to destroy everything
you can know and to keep the good that
is it murder for the greater good who
watches the mob yeah vanessa was the
watchman that the philosopher just like
makes the rules here well it's pretty
aggressive that is uh Oh close it's a
really sweet game and when can we expect
to get that we hope in June yes that's
optimistic I mean we still have so much
and we are short two people so we have
so much to address that way we can say
shown that it's a little bit optimistic
we shouldn't be here in San Francisco to
kill me
alright well that was Oh close you guys
can expect to see that later this year
hopefully on pc mac and linux and thank
you guys very much for watching and
thanks for being here no thank you for
having us
you